herzlich willkommen zum commercial
models zwischen escortservice und model
castings danke für mal führt kommentar
für diskussionen ich würde dem team auf
einzelne pünktlich liga als erstes ist
kommentar von sam shoemaker wo seit gern
erzählen etwas neues frau in der
opferrolle mit dem srf nicht einmal bis
über manch und mache jetzt ist es so
dass ward reportage ich mit rebecca mit
jazz und mit dem model agent mit dem
netbook mit dem peter koren über das
gerät und alle die ein kleid das so
angebot man bekommt also es ist nicht
nur frau es auch wasser gefunden haben
wohne ich mit dem motto selber kreta ist
dass die jacht parties und die exklusive
events wo irgendwo mit wachs in the
parties die er hauptsächlich frauen
beschrieben was ich gemacht habe ich
habe in dem stephen ätherisches
international als männermodel ich habe
mit ihm solche erfahrungen geräte und
was erst also für anfragen beherzigt was
ihm schon passiert ist also konkret was
ist dir passiert ja sie kann als
konkretes bild ich bin mit dem model
scout über insgesamt sechs große
karriere möglichkeiten besprochen das
große geld nie wieder so wie istanbul
kunde sein konto nein er ist endlich da
euro und krakau und das nach die cloud
wireless und schlussendlich hat er mir
nur dank des verkaufs im hotelzimmer sie
sind ja so sind momentan besten täter
mit gegangen und er hat mir so unterhose
geschenkt sondern das bafu
hat der dfb das ist mein istanbul ich
ein bisschen unbedingt machen
und ja es ist somit
moment sie sich sodann ist derzeit nicht
so aus es gab jetzt dem fall und
nachhaken wieso und würde mich auf einer
krise und die politiker zu ihren blog
inside man das comeback
des jahres
ja ich bin danach gegangen aber es ist
wirklich so in dem moment dank noch so
also wie
das zum mitmachen kann passieren und
hast du da sein irgendwann fertig oder
weiß der agentur oder irgendwie
agentur jetzt ne da haben die kollegen
sind wir dann nachher gottwik wegkommen
wir christen kollegin nirgendwo es am 10
aber es ist ein schwaches
peinlich sie zum verzehren will ich für
mich wie geschäumt haben sie
wahrscheinlich genau du kannst
historischen wahrscheinlich genau
gelesen archiv von kostet
ich finde dass bedankte befehligt für
jungen oder wurde auch schon von der
karriere sind wo sich die paare getraut
zum navi sie noch angst dass ihre
irgendwie
steinberg leiter dass sie irgendwelchen
twitter ja
denn der zweite kommentar sind sind zwei
der erste vom krug so fragt ob man die
rechtliche delhi ton vorgibt ist es rein
theoretisch aber was halt passiert im
auf instagram auf facebook ist dass die
nyt sich eben wurde oder aus versteckt
hinter dem also sicher nicht irgendwie
doug die kontaktangaben nicht irgendwie
didacta kontakt zu ihnen also sich sehr
sehr schwierig zum person war das profil
führt mal ausfindig zu machen müssten
über die instagram support gar über
facebook und die msi das nachher denn
die messe denn die e mailadresse fräger
oder das windrad polizei und die message
and ip adresse anonym also ich sehe ein
großer aufwand und das zweite oder
halten installiert 80 fragt ob man ihr
profil dann nicht einfach ein später
schaut auch schwierig also klar kann man
das machen viele melden aber instagram
und facebook braucht ein rechtes zieht
lieber dass da irgendwas gemacht wird
und sogar wenn also sogar wenn das
profil gesperrt wird der kann einfach
immer wieder neue machen und und es geht
wieder von vorne los es ist sehr
schwierig da konkret irgendwie besser zu
machen
social media plattformen selber
eigentlich praktisch überwältigt sind
von vielen spam und sache und also sich
sehr sehr schwierig denn der dritte
kommentare sind arbeiter zwei anlässe wo
sie sagen ob ich nämlich liegen energie
wenn ich das ganze abgang macht das
nicht
das ist das geht ich finde ich dass es
mit neue wie tz ich kann einfach weil
möglichst unfähig noah das thema habe
ich seit ich kann das verzählt büro und
hat den verein ja klar das geht sicher
und ja aber wenn ich das gemacht hat
dann war ich irgendwie vorliegen ob sie
interessant weil er verhindern und du
dass ich es so dass ganze angegangen wie
an es schlussendlich auch eine bewiesen
und kann derzeit gut es gibt es wirklich
nicht einfach erzähl ich war gerade wenn
man
seine
konkrete bewiesen dass sie mit einem
nachrichten mit gespräch mit den models
und und alle einig dass wir gerne
bewiesen dass es das gibt was
mich wirklich auffällt ist dass sie
immer noch eine finden war so angebot
verschickt und mir ist aber nur als
quartier wieder gleitet wurde schwer
wieder die spur und zwar ist das rating
auf eine party aber für die exklusive
party vom leonardo dicaprio wonach
gemacht vor lassen also im titel steht
leonardo dicaprio im örtlichen
e
mail leonardo dicaprio berlin
please contact the searchers und jetzt
ist die aufregung ganz explizit von hs
agenturen am fuß interesse
ist
verschickt wurde hätte party mit dem
leonardo dicaprio in berlin aber
gleichstark funde und frauen hat genug
wir denn die neugier für die event für
die parties rekrutieren ich habe leider
noch keine antwort und die ela da kann
ich jetzt einfach noch mal mehr zeigen
als beispiel für so explizit die angebot
wo man als frau aus marl einfach selber
wirklich an entscheiden möchte man das
machen oder nicht weil es ist klar
ersichtlich ruf was man sich aber muss
sich natürlich aus muss auch sehen dass
im model-business hat ideale
voraussetzungen sind für chrissi
machtverhältnis und zu dem thema von der
freiwilligkeit hat sich julian und
küsste sie seit folgendes die seit mitte
hat genau dieses thema aufs tapet
gebracht und auch deutlich gemacht dass
freiwilligkeit innerhalb solche
machtverhältnisse ein grundsätzlich
absolute begriff ist so absurd wie es
heute nicht wenigen von uns geht wenn
wir wegen unfähigen chefinnen leiden und
trotzdem unser maul halten weil es um
unsere existenz geht um unsere träume um
eigentlich einen guten job so bitte ich
also dringlichst sich nochmals mit dem
thema der sogenannten freiwilligkeit
auseinanderzusetzen im zusammenhang mit
der peter koren von der agentur
analysiert und kritisiert das signal
wichtig der faktor hand und kann
natürlich versucht sich an user also
einerseits dass es mit dem seriösen
model business tour hat dass man für
models zwar dass agentur romanisch aber
trotzdem nicht für alles verantwortlich
sie also doch liegt auch beleidigter
narr selbst verantwortlich und das ist
ganz klar das problem ist für social
media es im kommentar aus ergänzend
folgendes wenn ich nicht auch noah
nachrichtenagentur nonstop mit dem modus
kommuniziert dass kreise über social
media ag werden dürfen dass sie
regelmäßig ebs fotomodus überprüft das
kapital falsch verstanden werden dass
sie als agentur sieben tage der woche
immer erreichbar sind für models und wer
das model mit sechs oder escort versucht
wird sofort konsequenzen lassen ich
hoffe mit dem klienten es besser als
auch tiefes verständnis bekommt eine
thematik
reportage von rec abonniert jetzt noch
da der kanal auf youtube